[Applause]
two days to go before the spring budget
one big demand for more money
first of three days of strikes thousands
of Junior doctors called on the
government to listen
patience is difficult not to
on a hospital doorstep in Leeds
[Applause]
at an entrance of another in Bristol
[Music]
and on the steps outside one in London
a doctor that's gone through Medical
School done a minimum of five years
graduating with a hundred thousand
pounds of debt is being paid 14 pounds
an hour
you should be able to be a doctor get
paid a fair wage and work in NHS
that fair wage according to these
doctors is up to the government to
deliver but just listen to what the
health secretary thinks
35 as a demand is not affordable we've
offered to engage in constructed talks
with the junior doctors We Stand ready
to have those discussions
Carrie's also ready but the biopsy
appointment she had scheduled for today
was canceled she was meant to find out
if her cancer is back to now think I was
finally going to get some answers but I
I haven't is very frustrating and
worrying because you don't quite know
how things are progressing I had a scan
which indicates it's quite slow
progressing but every symptom every
little leg and pain you get you do worry
three days all in one go with not giving
the trust any information it's just
unworkable and it's unfair while doctors
and politicians wait to negotiate
patients like Carrie simply wait and
it's a nervous one Sadia Chaudhary Sky
News